yesterday i played a news clip for you
from
monday in which republican house
minority leader kevin mccarthy staged
a propaganda photo op sort of event at
the u.s mexico border
and at this event he claimed without any
evidence that turkish iranian
and yemeni terrorist undocumented
immigrants were coming over to the
united states
by physically and illegally crossing the
mexico
land border with the us here is kevin
mccarthy
saying it as i played for you yesterday
let's review the clip
and when you go to monument 3 and you
talk to those agents
it's not just people from mexico or
honduras or el salvador
they're now fighting people from yemen
iran turkey
people are on the terrorist watch list
they are catching and they're rushing it
all at once
now as i mentioned yesterday there is no
evidence of that but
it sounds really damn good and scary so
republicans have taken
off with it and this is quite literally
what we mean by memes it is a meme that
has caught on
and yesterday on fox news republican
congressman john catko
said the exact same thing and it is
spreading and it is becoming in the
absence of sort of like
real stories that fox news wants to
substantively cover
they are just grasping at straws as we
talked about yesterday
cancel culture dr seuss potato head uh
joe biden's
55 days without a press conference this
type of thing
now they're they've glommed on to this
take a listen to what catco
had to say addition to the migrants that
are crossing
um that there might be other bad actors
and possibly even
terrorists what did you hear from border
patrol yesterday
well it was a stunning revelation to be
honest with you we were at the edge of
where
new mexico mexico and texas meet and
it's called monument three we're sitting
up on a bluff
and we're asking the agents that they're
on the front lines and by the way there
is a big gap in the fence there
because of uh because of that they
stopped construction but
when i talked one of them was telling us
what they were seeing coming across the
border they saw over 100 people come
across in last few days in that
one little sector and he said some of
them are on the list and i said list and
he said
yeah the terror watch list and i i was
stunned and i've never heard that before
they said they've seized not just people
from central and south america
but even people from yemen in places in
the middle east that are
terrorism hotbeds so the claim is
that people on the terrorist watch list
from the middle east are crossing the
land border between the u.s and mexico
now
is it possible that this could happen of
course yeah
it could happen it is conceivable that
a suspected known terrorist from iran
could get themselves to mexico and then
cross over the border you know in the
middle of the desert that that
could happen a friend of the show
and former david pakman show guest
congressman ruben gallego
is on the subcommittee on intelligence
and special operations
he represents arizona a border state so
he would know something about this
and he tweeted quote weird as the
chairman
of the subcommittee on intelligence and
special operations
and a border state member of congress
haven't heard anything about this
going to ask for a briefing pretty sure
he is either wrong
or lying and the congressman went on to
say
hi republican leader meaning kevin
mccarthy
i have the same security clearance as
you do
can you have your office arranged for a
classified briefing for members
to see where this info derived from
uh customs and border patrol was asked
about this
they haven't commented and the truth is
that this is just
an old lie that is being refreshed once
again
donald trump told this lie in 2019
donald trump told this lie in january of
this year before leaving office he said
quote we have terrorists
from the middle east coming into our
country through the southern border
and he also mentioned it last night at
the uh earlier in the show we covered
this
very strange interview that donald trump
gave last night to
maria bartoromo and this was one of the
topics that came up donald trump again
made this claim
hey they're coming in you take a look
they're coming in from all foreign
countries i see they're coming in now
from yemen
they're coming in from the middle east
they're coming in from
everywhere they're dropping them off and
they're they're pouring into our country
if it's happening it should be dealt
with and taken seriously but there is
still no evidence that
people on the terrorist watch list from
iran
yemen and turkey are going to mexico
and then illegally crossing over to the
united states now if you're going to say
well david
if they're doing it illegally we don't
know we can't
we can't say for sure we don't know that
it's happening but we can't say that
it's not
well that's an indefeasible statement
that that would be as as
plausible as me saying you know there
are people from
australia going to argentina renting a
motorcycle and driving all the way north
and then riding the motorcycle uh
through the desert
you you can't say it's not happening
well then what are we talking about here
at some point we have to say what is the
evidence that this is going on
so this was actually floating around
during the obama years and it's
important to remember
just this one data point that the saudis
who did 911
came to the united states legally with
visas they took flight lessons at
american flight schools
you know all of this different stuff why
smuggle yourself
in through the southern border why even
send people already
on the watch list which could only
attract attention
it makes no sense it doesn't even pass
the sniff test
and i actually am wondering has there
been
any terrorist attacker on u.s soil
who came from the middle east over the
u.s mexico border illegally i i looked i
spent some time this morning looking
i wasn't able to find a single example
of
any uh wrongdoer i guess is the the term
assailant i don't know what term you
want to apply who did what is being
alleged here not a single example and i
by all means
if you find one let me know and i will
issue an update a correction call it
what you will
but yet another completely imagined
story
which as of yet is not supported by any
evidence whatsoever